You served in the Trump administration.
I have to ask you about
the news of the day,
the news that former
President Trump has posted on truth,
social
justice this morning,
that he expects to be arrested on Tuesday
and is also calling for protests,
telling his supporters to, quote,
take our nation back.
Your thoughts?
Well, just to explain,
if he is about to be arrested,
it almost certainly means he's
going to be indicted first.
He's going to be required to come in
and surrender himself
to answer to the indictment.
So it's not some random decision.
I strongly believe in a free society.
There's got to be one rule of law
for everybody.
I think that's clear.
I don't know how you make that judgment
when you're talking about a case
involving somebody
paying hush money
to a prostitute or a stripper.
I only know one person
who's ever done that.
I worked for him.
It's a kind of strange situation.
But I'll say this,
however guilty Trump may be
and having very much in mind
the one rule of law for everybody,
if they indict
and failed a convict in New York,
I think historians would look back
and say that is the act that reelected
Donald Trump president.
So I hope those prosecutors in New York
are very, very certain of their case.
Well, I've opined here that in the
the four buckets
that I perceive where he faces
legal peril.
This is, in my opinion,
the weakest of them.
And I have to believe
that there's a risk here of this
taint might not be the right word,
but tainting the prosecutions
that theoretically could follow.
He's got a right to vigorously
defend himself against this
and any other charges that might flow.
What I don't like
is him calling for protests,
because to me, it's
reminiscent of January six
Well, I think this is an important issue,
but my own view on January
the sixth is it was not an insurrection.
It was a riot.
It was one of the saddest days
in American history,
but it was not an attempted coup
because I didn't think Donald Trump
had the wit to conduct the coup.
But now, having seen the history,
if he's calling people into the streets
this time, he's
seen the experience of January the sixth.
And I think this is potentially
very dangerous.
So, again,
people law enforcement in New York
obviously has to be concerned
the safety of the citizens of New York.
But if something happens in this
that allows Trump to make it into
a campaign issue,
it's going to be very serious.
I know,
I know this must be
galling to many people,
but keep your eye on
the ball, is what I'd say.
If you don't want Donald Trump
to be elected
president again, for God
sakes, be careful how you act.
I get your point.
I mean, I
think I
and I think he risks
surrendering the argument
that this is a seven year old sex case
when if in fact,
it should lead to protests.
Hey, I like to respond to social media
in real time.
Catherine,
put something on the screen
so that the ambassador
and I can can answer it together.
I'll read it aloud, Ambassador.
And he's calling for his minions
to protest, says Gina.
He was careful with his wording
this time.
He'll be out before his fingerprint ink
can dry your thought
Well, he'll be out of the surrender
exercise on Tuesday, almost certainly.
I mean, you go in,
he's going to get his mug shot taken.
That that'll be interesting.
And he'll be back in some safe location.
We'll see what happens here.
We'll see how many people
are willing to turn out for him.
It may turn out to be a bust,
but but I don't think law enforcement
ought to do anything
that gives him an excuse to say
he's the most persecuted
man in the world.